listening to all the things you can't
hear
[Music]
and now for the adventures of the white
privilege boy
now okay timmy bobby and johnny if i've
told you once i've told you a thousand
times i need you to put your guns down
can't i just keep my gun on me trained
on you for just a little longer please
now boys you know i'm not supposed to
let you do that oh come on
all right just make sure it's unloaded
nope
no okay now okay now at least enough
that tech light you're blinding my eyes
what am i gonna do with you you little
rap scallions
oh those boys what tickle will they find
themselves in next stay tuned for next
week's installment of adventures of the
white privilege boys
this fall
six cities
prepare
for two
rebels with a cause
[Music]
phoenix
houston
charleston national new york
baltimore
[Applause]
the rebels with a cause comedy tour
tickets on sale now at
louderwithcrowder.com
tour
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
channel
[Music]
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
give me that that that hello
ahoy
i hope everyone's well today welcome
to loud with crowder with dave
also i would like to welcome some of the
other members that will be joining me
today gerald a
how are you sir ahoy how about you i am
doing well was that nutmeg is that what
give me that give me that nutmeg nutmeg
yes yeah nutmeg flavored tea tea oh it's
june tea
all right
started strong today yes that's what
we're doing we're opening it up big
we got uh of course we got token noun oh
hey there how are you good casey casey
kasem good morning there you go how are
you we'll go case them yeah i like that
today tim the tool man good morning good
morning and of course quarter black
garrett welcome to the show yo hey
what's up how are you doing dude i'm
doing good thanks for having me back on
thank you for coming in no problem i
love you bro all right i love you
brother and laying the brain how you
doing today i'm good but th that high
energy introduction i don't think i can
really match it quite yet so i'm going
to try to get in that level pretty soon
get up there a lot of pressure sit next
to it get on up up
to the east side
we are in a deluxe apartment in the sky
that's right
and uh crawdaddy had to sit out today
but we miss him we love him and i want
to tell you guys please uh
check us out on our tour
uh le rebels with a cause
you can check us out loudwithcrowder.com
tour go ahead and check out all the
dates there and you can catch me july
9th in lapeer michigan
at flanagan's pub
please come out enjoy that show
hopefully you will enjoy it or flanagan
mr flanagan we're gonna play bagpipes
it'd be a good irish funeral we'll be
drunk and we'll tell jokes yes what
happened it'll be fun eh oh cirrosis not
a surprise
alcohol poisoning what would have
thought never saw it coming out of an
irish
and then uh let's talk about question of
the day yeah what's the worst father's
day you've ever received or given
gifts can be gifted
what did i say gift well you didn't what
did i say
just the worst that's the worst father's
day
you've ever been given which actually
may be even funnier because like
what
yeah that's true maybe it's just mori
that's not
yeah just maury povich really like i
love when it's like you're not the
father and the dudes are doing
somersaults
and the kids crying in the front row
yeah like possibilities oh that's the
best when the kids like ate and
understands how happy the guy is not to
be his father no
it's like i haven't raised him for eight
years just leaves yeah
he's been sick he's been abandoned twice
thanks mori yeah thanks thanks for
having montel good guy oh montel great i
like jordan more or jerry alice yeah
jerry jerry jerry invented it he did
yeah he's the problem he's the og
patient zero well he's the one jerry who
wrote a check to a prostitute
when he was mayor of cincinnati that's
right yeah never had cash yeah
and then he was like well you just be a
scumbag tv host and he was right ah and
that's why i'm a fan right it wasn't
i always we used to watch baywatch and
that and uh jerry after show back to
back yeah yeah that was
those
that was a good idea yeah it was
and you turned out
perfect just fine look at you now i
shouldn't do that that's been clipped
all right
can we got that slide cut that no well i
got some good
it will be cut and used against me
a random tick tocker is finally admitted
to the purpose of neo pronouns
exciting so neopronouns are any set of
pronouns that aren't officially
recognized in the language that you use
someone might use neopronouns because
uh officially recognized pronouns might
give them dysphoria this is from the
site no fans could give someone german
i use them because they give me euphoria
um because i really enjoy confusing
people with my gender identity
which sounds kind of weird but it gives
me euphoria so whatever you get i really
like using lay them and faithful
in conversation like when i'm talking
and i really like using bun bun self uh
like if i'm texting someone or
i guess just on the internet
um that's that's the way i like using
them so an example of faith fair
pronouns could be i think i really like
the jacket today it's the parent's name
yes
your parents do not relate to sweet
child online could be
bunched up on my for you page today bond
really likes using neo pronouns
so she admits they're nonsense ah yeah
absolutely she's just a jerk did she say
bon bon self bon bon or bun bun was it
bon bon i think she's making it up i
think she doesn't even know she doesn't
know she likes confusing people she
likes pissing people off good luck in
life
well that's what she said they're for is
to confuse you and it's like right that
was the agenda yeah and it gives me
euphoria yeah that's really just ssris
that's not euphoria yeah no it's not
stis yes ssris
i'm sure she has both i'm sure she's
i'm sure she's on lithium and has sgis
i don't know i like confusing people and
myself yeah i just i do this with my
hands she didn't blink one time just
distracting you no oh no i yeah she
tries to remind herself to wet her eyes
every half hour
[Laughter]
dry eyes why do you have dry eyes i'm
stuffed with pills
and i can't blink
help me
[Laughter]
oh you've ruined blue hair remember when
it was cool in slc punk a little bit it
was awesome back in the day i remember
thinking it was cool it's like oh man i
want to get it got repurposed
some hair color reappropriated cool yeah
i'm bringing it back i'm bringing my
mohawk back i'm dying blue and i'm going
full
lpga well dave it was nice to have
worked with you
all right so
i mean that look that look is in right
now it is no it's hot it's not it is it
is it's you can't deny it that's that's
what all the kids are doing i can deny
it you can't deny it i'm a straight
rider you don't want to that's all right
i can't say other words no i know it
will be thrown off of youtube because
it's so good yeah moral not on
juneteenth no not a teenager well it's
not juneteenth technically it's the day
what that was observed for a federal
holiday juneteenth is a state of mind
yes oh wow to live in lane knows the
struggle right well now he's ginger i'm
sitting next to someone that is almost
fully
black i almost feel the struggle yeah
every day i think about it and i was
mostly struggling are you excited that
they finally
i'm so happy to what day was it was it
today it was yesterday today is observed
he celebrated
six hours yesterday because that's all
he's allowed that in kwanzaa yeah
favorite holidays that were made up yeah
exactly yeah today's the day that they
white people acknowledge that yesterday
happened yep
and history
[Laughter]
do you see bill nye his tweet no america
was built on the backs of slavery and i
was like yeah and like you know settlers
and a bunch of other people mm-hmm as
well yeah it was mostly very specific
well thank you bill can you just
do science experiments for kids now yeah
yeah thanks and talk about butt stuff
like your song
that was great
that was his tweet oh he dressed
can be up or fashionable you can't be
both dave no that's true he can't be
brilliant please don't give that to him
apparently you can do it both halfway
so he's tv science yeah he's tv science
i could be tv science just put a prompt
in front of me and i'll pretend like i
know what i'm talking about i'm doing it
right now so
former vice president biden uh decided
to take a two-wheeler out for a ride on
saturday
it didn't go well
yay mr president
[Music]
uh sure left the training wheels on
come on man like it's we've all fought
bikes before you know it happened i was
12.
yeah he's like 108 years old yeah man
yeah that's true i mean that's true it's
not like we should judge someone's
capacity to do their job on their
ability to ride a bike
look at what fox news saw on saturday at
rehoboth beach delaware
this is joe biden out there on a
vigorous bike ride vigorous not wearing
a harness but definitely wearing a mask
by the way
oh my god fox's narrative and
talk radio's narrative for months
has been that joe biden is falling apart
you just heard ben shapiro say it
falling apart
and there he is riding a bike for a bike
ride and fox of all networks is the one
that showed it happen
i stand corrected time to brush off the
old 25th amendment yes i love that he
was wearing a mask out in the great
outdoors
well it's important it's as important as
brian stelter is to news
how many times has he flipped a bike
right because he heard an ice cream
truck and he pulled the hearts like hold
on get my foot out of this rig yeah i
just ran out the door and just tripped
over some blue belt own crocs smashed
his face oh i won oh i wanted an eclair
i got hung up with my purse
i gotta admit when i first saw this clip
i was like oh okay well i've i've
actually almost fallen over doing the
exact same thing so if you're writing if
you're a cyclist or you're writing and
you clip your feet in sometimes you you
try to unclip and it doesn't come out
and i was like wait but he's not clipped
in no he was riding a huffy yeah he had
the simplest like stick your foot your
toes in here and that'll keep your toes
from coming out all you had to do is
why are they having them do this he we
he's had trouble climbing you know
stairs stairs yeah yeah like there's no
just walking just having difficult for
him right you shouldn't have him doing
anything well you notice that he was
wearing a helmet this time the secret
service is right we cannot take any more
chances sir you should have it have him
in an airport or sorry every time he
gets into air force one just put a
helmet on him when his pr person rolled
out his plan for the day did this not
literally rolled out because it's right
that's right yeah that's right lol
was this not the obvious end to the day
like this all paths lead to joe biden
falling off right yeah they should plan
around that like this is a red flag
let's like worry about him being on a
bike yeah with no training wheels on
yeah they can't walk man no well well
he's he biden says he's okay though oh
god oh he didn't exactly well he didn't
exactly say he's okay it was it was more
like a weird game of charades
mr president how are you feeling
how are you step steps
good there you go
what i think you just taped himself he
remembers that move from the
playboy 60s
listen um based on that are we sure he
didn't suffer any like you know brain
damage or something like that during
that fall well there was uh brain
bleeding a little bit of a seizure um
and he's having trouble talking so no
he's fine exactly the same totally
normal nothing changed okay all right
baseline for him can't tell no it's
totally good
yeah i think i'm with you i don't know
why anybody would pull out like we
should we should ride a bike
you know then we'll have him juggle
maybe do magic and then afterwards he'll
hop yeah a couple of times and let the
media know that he's surprised super
dexterous someone in that administration
is trying to kill him i i
i'm thinking the same thing that's the
vice president on the itinerary like you
know pogo stick let's do some pogo stick
next time yeah let's just juggle a
little harder flaming darts you can do
all this let's play jarts
[Laughter]
watch lawn dart
oh my god kill everyone
mr vice president you ever tried to tame
a cobra wow
that's a great idea i think i could do
it
give me the shade
all right so i helped look cool i wear a
top hat and i have a stool there's a
line i can do that yeah yeah no problem
me and my friend we used to do that in
mumbai yeah i spent time there
i spent more time with indians than any
president that ever existed that's true
oh boy
no i'm sure you guys all saw the new uh
buzz lightyear movie um
hell no no no yeah i refuse i totally
missed that one oh
i guess i i also didn't
uh but
it debuted this weekend and it was a
giant big stinking flop oh neither did
anybody else well that's odd that's so
weird when you take the star out
yeah uh the film grows 51 million
dollars which was far behind it's real
uh projections you know of uh 70 million
lowest pixar debut of all time right
behind cars 3. wow yikes pixar's usually
pretty good about releasing popular
films oh well yes
it's uh kind of the general ideas disney
sucks
and people are starting to figure that
out they're ruining everything yeah i
always thought the lowest uh
pixar movie was schindler's list two hmm
yeah
shouldn't have made that one a funny
favorite one no
it was boogaloo though there was a lot
of dancing in it a lot it was very disco
yeah and you're like i they don't look
healthy enough to dance but they get
down they got down hey like it's really
cardboard energy you gotta you gotta
fight against the power yeah amen dance
i hate boxing that's how they get their
country back
uh
the
the film finished just behind jurassic
world
uh which is uh also horrible it's just a
horrible movie
imagine your your pixar disney pixar
right right and you finish behind a
movie that's the third movie in a bad
trilogy
in its second weekend in its second
weekend right wow
well why do you keep making it you're
disney you're like you know we need to
keep being woke and going the completely
wrong direction what you've never done
you've never been moral before what
you're pretending to why are you doing
it now
i don't know i think i really do think
it's audiences figuring it out like
their
their marketing strategy of doing this
whole lgbt thing and
saying screw you literally the week it
opens yeah with chris evans saying
they're all dinosaurs dinosaurs anybody
that thinks differently than me uh
they're all going to die off
that's a great market we haven't gotten
ironic oh we're gonna get to that
actually yeah you're right because that
is
indeed
yeah it's a literary framing but it also
barely beat top gun which is in its
third week yes
killing it and it's still killing us
above this yeah and uh yeah well this is
it's good that you brought that up
experts are scratching their heads
trying to figure out where it all went
wrong
but it uh definitely wasn't because of
this
whenever you do something about
representation or diversity or whatever
you sure there's always push back um i
mean what would you i mean how would you
counter that i suppose well i mean the
real truth is those people are idiots i
mean i think throughout history you can
see every time there's bugness
yes so call your fans call your
potential audience idiots that's going
to get him to come
come to the american story
is one of constant makes me wonder about
awakening and growth and that's that's
what
that's what makes us good and then you
know when that happens there's always
going to be i don't know what it is
about his shirt is but it makes me
anxious
that sounds like an unaware voice almost
and trying to hold on to what was before
but those people die off like dinosaurs
and so you know i think the the goal is
to pay them you know march forward and
and and embrace
the growth that makes us human i would
say to those people just like with buzz
like
you know
re refurbish your idea of tradition you
know understand that it's now it's to
infinity and beyond it's spacex
did she just quote the movie uh enjoy
all the things
i've always been there you know what i
mean they always been a part of the
picture well infinity
so what this is about is about this is
the this is what it looks like this is
what it's always been and yeah to
infinity and beyond yeah
yeah yeah yeah juneteen
would anybody else like some juneteenth
ice cream come on over here
what infinity means
there is no beyond it's a joke it's a
stupid light at a movie that's ironic
hey
that's a great one there's enough right
now don't trash the lion like we're
dying on a weird hill here yeah yeah
yeah i just think it's funny that she's
like yeah infinity beyond and then she
repeats it like that's that's what she's
doing to stand up for this i just don't
want the mega irony to be lost that he
said they'll go the way of the dinosaurs
yes but they lost to jurassic world
that is very true i went to call yikes
all the dead dinosaurs were brought back
to life and they're beating you
they're brought back to life for the
sixth time and they beat you on their
second week
sorry chris maybe go back to being
captain america well he already gave
that up well you can't say it's already
black yeah which is fine i would rather
have it be anybody yeah anybody at all i
would just like it to be somebody who
has american values how about that'd be
nice
in hollywood yeah well no playing
somebody that has american vegetables
for 10 captain america
pretend to be somebody that has american
values yeah i don't think we can do that
no that's too hard for them they can't
act anymore truth just right in the
american way they're not allowed or
direct yeah well you're a superman no i
know that's what i'm saying
well thank you well that's that's a
different superhero yeah i was going to
do your connection just watch superman
four you're gonna love it all right
all of this surrounding the controversy
of the lesbian relationship depicted in
the film
as bloomberg ugh just read it
i have the worst dry mouth from that
happens claritin don't worry the film
also faced bands abroad and ire from
conservative political figures
in the u.s who say the movie's fictional
space inhabitants and a same-sex couple
couldn't naturally produce children that
the portrayal violates their religious
beliefs yeah so it's basically saying
two chicks couldn't have kids i've heard
that that is absolutely 100 true it's
science it was also a needless part of
the movie that was the thing like it
didn't need to be in the movie that's
what most people were commenting on like
you wedged something in there for an
agenda and that was it you should have
just taken it out it would have been
fine there's no relationships in any of
the others toy story movies because
they're totally yeah well and then
they're also a military space unit why
would there be relationships like where
we're flying into space fighting
monsters and stuff like what what's the
point there's some some pretty graphic
stuff with slinky dog in the first movie
actually whoa
remember it's in the post-credit
delivery yeah and when they bring in mr
potato head mrs potato head which is now
one thing
she was shoving stuff up his butt yeah i
did i do remember that totally it was
just different parts yeah he didn't need
any arms and ears and stuff hands
eventually it's just a potato with every
pizza
[Laughter]
it still looks more believable than
other toys
it's all accurate just woody's head
completely suffocated
[Laughter]
but he enjoys it
yeah this is great
oh my gosh excuse me isn't there now
just uh it's not mystery it's just
potato head potato probably yeah you're
not allowed to have a world that we live
in man you can't even have mr potato
head i feel like something happened and
we did end up in the bizarro universe
that yeah
it wasn't supposed to be it's certain
it's whenever they collided those
particles together yeah blew us into
this [ __ ] timeline just this absurd
oh am i right what is uh
i guessed this look mister head was
always that way it was a potato by the
way this was marketing genius we'll sell
you two different mr potato head and mr
mrs potato head and all the all the
differences is the parts it's a mustache
the potatoes the same mustache just the
difference
mrs potato head did have a thing on her
if we're gonna be honest oh a booty yeah
for sure because that's also where you
would store all the parts
you could just store more she was
packing a little heat how much junk can
you fit in that trunk yeah except now mr
potato heads is much bigger
there's already stuff in there you're
like what is this huh well just room for
a vibrator
[Laughter]
another factor that probably didn't help
this film was the decision to not cast
oh what's his name tim allen that's
right you mean buzz yeah buzz lightyear
yeah
yeah you know the guy who played him
what for the last 27 how long have you
ever been 25 25 years is it 25 years 25
years
yeah former everybody loves raymond star
patricia heaton tweeted
saw this trailer for buzz lightyear and
all i can say is disney pixar made a
huge mistake in not casting
tim allen tim allen in the role that he
originated
the role that he owns tim is buzz why
would they completely castrate this
iconic beloved character i agree yeah
they replaced tim allen which is a
little too you know
conservative for disney they replaced
him with chris evans which chris evans
is basically a communist
at this point if you've ever followed
any of the things you said no no no he's
a christian communist oh sure i totally
believe that yeah
and i'll name drop i've worked with tim
allen hey
but uh
on the street but near him i follow him
yeah
i which part of tim allen's career did
you work
yeah i just follow him uh behind him
when he's home so i get pulled over
because he's drunk driving
[Laughter]
but no i uh i've i opened for him a
couple times and uh
he's
who he built abc let's be honest
improvement
saved that network built brought in
was that it he built abc get it
you're on today
i'm glad you're catching them
but he abc disney yeah
and then they fired him of course
because he had a difference of opinion
yeah and then you know now they're
getting rid of him from his actual and
what i hate chris evans not even doing a
buzz light your voice no he's being
chris evans in it you're not even trying
to be the buzz light your character
i hate this yeah i guess i'd have to
watch the movie to even know but i
there's no way i was like i saw light
year no way i'm going to go back to that
they're going to move they're going to
ruin it well the real problem is like
okay let's say there's two women kissing
in it
fine
why does that have to be the promo of
your film
it doesn't work it doesn't work
the thor movie is coming out right 11
thunder and that's supposed to also have
like a lesbian character i think king
valkyrie or whatever which is dumb why
is her name king whatever there's queens
yeah okay move on
can you feel angry
but
she's supposed to have like a love
interest in that
and they used to use that as like a
promo in like 2020 when the movie was
gonna come out but then it's been pushed
and pushed and pushed and now the
audiences don't
receive that very well obviously
light year as an example so they've
stopped using that as like a marketing
pull so
once they've come back
you don't hear that anymore you don't
hear oh there's there's a gay
representation in this film it's just
like come to our superhero movie please
god because we are crashing and burning
every time we put out a movie unless
it's spider-man and we're ruining these
things and the investment king valkyrie
there you go yeah that's her
well she might as well be driving a
subaru look at that one hey
they they
are you serious that's they who knows i
have no idea i don't care i'm trying to
be safe well let's go back to purple
lady from the beginning and she'll tell
us
just to piss us off all right anyway
there was some speculation allen's uh
conservative values were to blame oh
[ __ ] yeah anyway
however disney will be working with alan
on a new santa claus project oh good
releasing this fall yeah
you know it's not it's not it's not all
good news though
because apparently alan santa claus
falls off the roof and is replaced by a
transgender little person
oh man what is going on beautiful and
brave
okay and she's top notch right in time
she's pretty good
she gains a little bit of weight and
just dies
[Laughter]
got the sugar foot
i hurt so bad it just isn't a wheelchair
like destroyer the whole movie
just drinking herself to death
on a little rascal scooter rudolph
commits suicide it's a really sad tale
yeah it sounded so sick good it can be
modernized can't make today's deliveries
just can't pick anything up because it's
bones hurt yeah yeah identified as a
light bulb this whole life and nobody
ever saw him every gift on the list is
just puberty blockers
it's really easy for those elves to to
make like sprinkling them like candy
just pfizer is the
north pole buy one get one gender
reassignment surgery coupons
to all the good boys and oh oh boy i
can't even already miss gendered yeah
rewrite this list i don't get to stay
home this year though
but it looks like americans are finally
using their wallets to push back against
the woke agenda and i think that's good
yeah you know it's like it's about time
we finally just say
we don't
need this in kids movies we don't need
anything in kids movies except for you
know kids comedy yeah exactly well i
think having top gun maverick out there
just having a pure like movie that's fun
that doesn't paint america as being
horrible
does incredibly well is the highest
grossing movie i think ever for tom
cruise now will probably surpass a
billion dollars that's fantastic and you
see right after it more woke stuff and
it's not just us complaining
it's people's pocketbooks saying we
don't want to pay for it we're done we
are absolutely done and by the way
disney
quarterblack and i were talking about
this before the show like they just they
take stuff and they ruin every single
piece of it right like with all the star
wars stuff that they're doing
you know not they didn't do halo
obviously but this same kind of
mentality of let's do something really
cool like an origin story for buzz
lightyear
that's kind of a stretch for me in the
first place and then you ruin it by
getting rid of tim allen and then you
throw stuff in that doesn't need to be
there to like push awoke agenda like
well really with a toy the origin story
would just be a five-year-old asian kid
building it well that's true yes
it should just be a factory floor with
you know a little bit of uh a kid yeah a
kid who's never allowed to play with a
thing he made
let's send this to america yeah yeah
right here oh my fingers hurt well i
guess you're gonna get shot in the alley
look at those tiny fingers though yeah
let's get in there
they're just so perfect those little
ones don't forget their feet they can't
run they're the best little snow piercer
reference i like that yes
it's chris chris evans too right isn't
he in there yes yeah the movie he is
yeah i'm a big fan full circle
it sucks because i do actually like
chris evans i think he's a good actor
and he's good in movies but damn he's a
dumbass yeah he is a dumbass yeah it's
not like uh who's the guy who plays hulk
i always forget his name because mark
ruffalo yeah
yeah i just don't like him yeah yeah so
like as a person or i never really liked
his acting enough to be like i enjoy him
yeah mark ruffalo doesn't like mark
ruffalo no he doesn't know it turns into
a big green sponsor you can't be that
miserable and enjoy your life
he looks like
god just stopped making him halfway
through
so that'll do
from a soulless ginger come on
oh my god i have red hair dave did you
know did you really yeah i didn't notice
sort of making this soul fire crotch
and trust me i've seen it it's a beaut
my son if it makes you feel any better
he has a little bit of red hair right
now i got somewhere in here right here a
little red blue says that
to to compensate for what he just said
yeah it's like saying i have a black
friend
my son has a red hair yeah i'm also
going to dye my son's hair don't worry
yeah get rid of it my brother has red
hair
i mean i don't talk to him
my point exactly
i don't know what's wrong with that i
have red hair it'll grow out of my beard
sometimes yeah really yeah i don't know
eight little stragglers i'm a mutt
davey i'm an irish and italian my body
doesn't know what to do it's it's been
confused it's like what do i do what do
you what do you wanna eat potatoes or
mustard trolley
thank god this wedding meal comes with
both
it's a live show monday through thursday
at 10 a.m rumble
bam
anywhere you can find podcasts i i i
like spotify
what uh apple apple podcast got google
podcast mug club club you can go to blog
club yes
you can uh subscribe right there and
then of course the thing we're on right
now
the youtubes for youtube
now uh yesterday was a big day i think
for a lot of people in this room big day
happy father's day by the way yeah yeah
yeah yeah see we got it's a lot of them
the tool man
gerald a happy father's day father's day
to you sir and of course happy father's
day to you thank you very much can't we
observe father's day today if they can
observe juneteenth today i think so
i think we should get more gifts could
you get out of the room please
[Laughter]
if we're going to be racist the whole
show no
i didn't say we couldn't do juneteenth
again as well father's day observation
commence again
i bet you
wow i'm not going to say what that is
going to say father's day observe would
be funny because there are a lot of
people that have to just observe it
that is true
that could be white people's dads left
that's true lots of them my dad's dad
left foot away yeah he was irish the
black people of white people
is that a thing that is true though
yeah well let's get to these
they were discriminated against the
irish they were the most hated yes
no black people and no irish irish was
always dead last it was like no blacks
no italians no irish and then you know
thank goodness we switched once they
realized we're a little
worse
yeah you made the top of the list if
nobody comes in moving on yeah it looks
good like i'm happy that's why we
brought lukosa nostra with us from italy
we're like fine we'll take it
[Music]
figured out on our own
else the irish mob they are ruthless
jewish mob ruthless really hardcore none
of the mobs that i've heard of have been
like oh they're nice they're nice folk
well i think the russians are the ones
no there's italians that are super cool
the people are yeah
but uh the mob itself
well if if you're on their beds yeah you
gotta be on the good side yeah i don't
wanna is there a good site yeah when you
don't take a loan from them oh there you
go
then they're pretty cool to you but then
it's like if you borrow 20 bucks for the
rest of your life they're like i think
you owe me 20 bucks so like i paid you
every day for the last 30 years
it's the vig yeah it's what it's called
20 bucks a day all right i got empty
pockets right now though yeah that's all
i'm saying i'll take what you've got
candy corn are you irish lane no what
are you
english and german are you right yeah
[Laughter]
what i just assumed you look irish
i i can understand where that
observation was he's way too tall for
that he's way too oh that's true he is
tall are you you're part irish right um
part irish and uh german as well yeah
irish black and german yeah you must not
like yourself yeah it's a lot of
internal a lot of fighting fighting
allowed in most places no no including
his own body yeah
i identify as bing bong now
i want you guys to all use pronouns bing
bong bing bong until i change that yeah
that's going to happen being self
being self
yesterday uh well yesterday of course
people got a lot of gifts because it was
father's day and juneteenth and uh
people dozens of people celebrated both
and these uh holidays are both
absolute
handfuls
[Laughter]
just i can count on one hand how many
people were at a juneteenth father's day
party how many
i received a lovely gift from my my son
it's you yep it was a it was a piece of
rope called an epstein necktie what did
you get i i got some shirts from the
wife oh yeah yeah
polos no no i have already had plenty of
pokemon
what did they what were they there's
some like short sleeve button-down uh
summer shirts fabulous yeah there you go
and i will say this i will bring them up
one time pictures of my kids faces on a
pair of socks well that's nice
and i rock those things i love it i
thought that was the funniest thing i
would like it make sure that those not
with your kids i think no
i don't wear
[Laughter]
sold out in like five minutes and that
sucks i mean there's no not socks i went
to 46 year old single hollywood types
those sound like pretty good gifts
though yeah there's got to be some kind
of crappy gifts out there but i think
there are yeah i think they are what did
you get though real quick anything good
well i got myself a game boy
and then some games for it and not even
that's not even black and white that's
just a greenish tint yeah yeah it's now
well now it's like sunburned and yeah
off colored i love it yeah and you can't
even see the screen you have to like
angle it at the sun and you can play
yeah you bought garbage uh no it's
[ __ ] it's that's an artifact man it
belongs in a museum but now it's in my
room i'm with you all right i had
virtual boy do you remember that oh yeah
yeah i was like one of the eight people
who's just burnt out
yeah you just put it in there and slowly
you went blind yeah you're like this is
great i can't wait to get lasik this is
the future yeah
i bet you there were a lot of terrible
gifts though like uh you said laying the
brain so here we are seven plus one
worst father's day gifts ever
[Music]
y'all forgot to find in the chamber
every time
number seven lane
i'll start sure at jockstrap for caitlyn
jenner yeah oh oh not a good gift that's
a specific gift there you can hit the
like button too hit the like button now
we're gonna hit that later number six a
unicycle for joe biden
i would love to see that wouldn't you
uh no
what's the next one five double five
five is what we call it number five qb
a toy train for woody allen oh
let's see what he would do is he's
he'd i don't want to know what he would
do with him he'd bring him up to the
attic and uh
the train was not the part that was fun
for him
oh number four gerald a
a big book of baby names for george
foreman
[Laughter]
georgina georgette
just all jordans georges
georgionda look be happy i'm we're rich
yeah
jojo get these grills
number three unlimited minutes for alec
baldwin
stay on the phone all day and call your
daughter a pig
and then ex
and then shoot people on a movie set and
pretend like you were on the phone well
speaking of which
number two lane the brain
a 38 pistol for marvin gaye senior oh
man his home man sorry we're on we're
observing juneteenth okay yeah and butch
i love marvin gaye i love one of my
favorite ever he's like what's going on
your dad has a gun and he's upset
and number one a home gym for chris
benoit
it's very nice
[Laughter]
and there's one in the chamber always of
course qb
a lizzo calendar for crawdaddy he's out
there we've already got it printed
he's gonna love it
thank you that has been seven plus one
[Music]
gets them every time i always there's
always one in the chamber don't forget
it don't forget
well yeah whoever bought the home gym
for
that's horrible yeah not a good idea
right no no
um oh well deep lore i feel like
a lot of people know that
yeah i'm sure they're googling it and
like right now i'm being like well they
have another tab open right now heavens
to betsy oh what is this
excuse me his own neck
all right
gym accidents not good
yeah be safe in the gym well it's more
of a gym on purpose except the
the 88-year-old alzheimer's biden brain
that he had yeah anyway
hoping to put an end to father's and
mother's day there were pro-abortion
protests this past weekend
we are here at justice amy coney
barrett's house today with our arms tied
with our mouths covered holding dolls
because this is what amy's america looks
like children will be forced to give
birth to children women will be silenced
women will be invalidated
women will be told they are less than
women will be told they are inferior
and that is not okay
so all of you who say you are pro-choice
get up and say out loud get up take to
the streets and stay
because you cannot let this happen to
your sisters to your daughters to your
mothers you can't let this future happen
to us
it's not fair
i'm not seeing any covered mouths
there's a lot of mouths there
that is of course 15 year old ariana who
organized the protest doesn't she have
maybe a few better things to do on a
weekend than worrying about killing
babies
well i guess it's uh letting every guy
in school know that she's willing to
take a cream pie and then get rid of the
other oh
too much
i don't know if you guys know how men
think yeah she's also a 15 year old yeah
she's like children but she's having
children yeah well why are they having
sex
yeah children should not be doing that
right no you're not responsible for
granted if i was 15 i don't know if i'd
agree but
if you were 15. if i'm 15. well that's
no you're older you're wiser yeah i had
sex for the first time when i was 15.
allegedly
no there's there's biological proof i'm
not saying that there's anything well
not anymore yeah i was dating her
she has no problem
i went undercovers all right
what
are you worried i i mean
heard i'm just she just confuses me the
whole shtick does she have parents or
did they like abort themselves like
where are they like what
i think judging by the upper crest
neighborhood she has very little
problems and this is her creating one
that was amy coney barrett's house
uh well no they did proceed to walk by
justice amy coney barrett's house with
blood painted on their pants one one
wasn't painted but it was her monthly uh
they
taped their mouths and of course dolls
to their hands
[Laughter]
that's better there's like five of them
it's more silent yeah no one cares ah
that's so weak you're just looking for
something to do and to be enraged about
because you don't understand the life
like wait just wait a few years you'll
realize it sucks well and don't go to
the women will be lesser than it's like
no no this is not like this is not about
choosing to do something to your body
it's choosing to do something to the
body that's inside of you that just
happens to be a resident maybe we should
allow people to kill tenants in
apartments at that point well if we were
in my place well i allowed them to be
there but it doesn't matter well if we
up the age of abortion to 16 years old
their parents probably gonna be waiting
at home with a sawed-off
she's to be like i'm pro-life now
should be pro-life always
yeah what's your hot take
i'm sorry
i'll take the tape off my mouth that i'm
not wearing a little late you don't
usually see the early setting up of the
protest yeah i think that's humorous to
me a little bit because i like to see it
like oh let's get the get we do get the
right tape oh it hurts a little bit but
in my mouth yeah also why do they all
have such a heavy flow
yeah quite a bit of blood it's a lot of
blood and white pants very tacky i
wouldn't wear white pants no and this
time of year no
very it's a bad idea why is she bleeding
that's a fashion abortion well they
should i wish those were all real and
they had to go shark diving yes i don't
even know what shark diving is i just
want to watch it but you also have the
stigmata no cage
like there's a great tampax commercial
in there somewhere oh yeah for sure
how do you
keep hitting hitting those laps
[Music]
he's really good it's funny
you didn't think it was funny
quarterback i thought it was hilarious i
enjoyed it then why didn't you laugh
there really should be a commercial we
just air of that and then just have
tampax at the end
because your daughter's an idiot yeah
uh ariana and her friends shared more of
their thoughts with us thank goodness
so now that you put these outfits on
does it make you feel any kind of way
it makes me feel terrified but also
powerful
and like we're doing something important
because this is how a lot of women
this is what a lot of women are doing
people who are actually dying and
bleeding out because they can't get a
safe abortion no that's not how this is
the terrifying visual of what america is
going to look like it's a terrifying
visual that children are giving birth to
children
i've heard that before the eight
promiscuous girls in high school are
protesting
are they holding up the fat girl's
underwear who wasn't invited
the only reason that ariana signed on is
so she could get camera time you saw
like she was like butting in like it's
terrified but also powerful but
terrifying well they don't know what
they're talking about i'm the leader
yeah exactly shut up oh yeah the one
girl starts talking and she just
immediately interrupts her just like
it's terrifying
that's not on the script
[Laughter]
but also powerful camera here i said
camera here
i often when you feel terrified you also
don't feel powerful
it's part of the feeling of terror
it kind of might be you know opposites
there i'm horrified but i'm also
blissful
[Laughter]
you're 15. go be 15. you sound stupid
yeah i was stupid when i'm 15. maybe i
am now but still
i didn't tape my mouth shut
she should have taped it shut more i
will it would have been better yeah
i do notice that they started with oh we
got our mouse covered and then it
completely gave that up every single
shot after that
no mouse covered i think except for when
the meal comes any holiday gathering 15
year olds should have to tape their
mouth shut mm-hmm
i think that's fair just because they're
thoughts
and i just want to eat i just want to
sit there i'm going to
eat
and move on
watch watch my movie i just keep talking
yeah that's it i don't want to hear your
opinion because you're familiar with
asking me questions i'm like i don't
want to talk to you little kid i don't
know you guys are jerks why you sure
what do you want to talk to a 15 i'm
talking about my kid gerald i want to
help them understand you want to meet
chris hanson
come over here sit down take a seat sit
down
put the gatorade in the cheetos down it
says here you are
a and the a is for a lot of [ __ ]
was this you this is your chat log here
i love how it's always the worst name
it's imaginable
it's like i want to bang 15 year olds
like we were just friends we were just
having a nice conversation none of it
was sexual at all well it says i want
you i want to bleep you in your bleep
with your bleeps hide behind your bleep
and yes i mean this sexually yes last
part probably is have you ever protested
in front of amy coney barrett's house
i'd like to know
i hope you don't protest what i'm about
to do to you oh
originally allegedly
uh except abortions have all but ended
in south dakota pending the release
of the scotus decision
you guys know that governor christie
gnome is that right a woman a woman by
the way is she a full woman or where are
we
like she's pretty hot okay so we're
talking about a real one may i see it
listen yeah let's see real woman yeah
hold on we need to update she's like
cowgirl hot okay so she's like a real
woman yeah okay
she's not
she's like home on the prairie like
rodeo cowgirl
okay like bunny hop hot buckle bunny oh
i think he meant like biting bunny he's
like daisy duke
like you wouldn't mind getting wrangled
by christy gnome if you know what i'm
saying oh my god daisy duke
daisy duke for sure all right okay nice
of her to pick up that young amish girl
the family carriage ran off the road
okay
governor uh yeah christine a woman
celebrated the closure of the last
abortion clinic in her state by saying
abortions have stopped in south dakota
we have prayed for this day and now it
is here
now we must
redouble our focus
is that right it is great we must
redouble our focus on taking care of
mothers in crisis
help is available for you adoption is an
option
you are never alone and i love that she
said that second part because the claim
from the left is that we only care about
kids while they're in the womb and then
after that they they're on their own
because they say we oppose social
spending and other things like that care
of it's like no we oppose giving away
free stuff
with money that we don't have that
doesn't actually solve the problem and
so she's kind of taking that and heading
it off and saying look now that this is
happening we have to make sure that
mothers in crisis and kids that are born
into poverty are getting the help that
they need not handouts not free stuff
for the rest of their life to be
dependent on the government yeah but
actual help so hopefully that that helps
her in her it doesn't matter they're
gonna oh they are gonna call her a
murderer her constituents love what
she's doing and that's really all that
matters for her in her state well so far
there's been no women taking to the
streets uh with uh dead babies duct
taped to their hands
really
well that's i'm surprised yeah fake ones
of course well yes yeah 15 year olds
domestic and by women i mean children um
having children children having children
in the streets i think the bigger
problem is children you're gonna do the
streets children babies pants don't do
that
you don't know me but i'm your mother
all right
that's not a song i know it's an eye
change it's a mother you're taking it to
the streets lane you look upset you're
all right no angry is it because i'm
good it's pensive is it because of the
the ginger things are starting to boil
over i just is that it
no i'm fine i didn't do it no i'm just
kidding i'm just kidding i call you
laying the brain because i think you're
a sharp guy i'll survive he's very sharp
and he does have a soul if if we need a
quick uh during show pick me up charity
says gingersnap is as hot as chris evans
look at that
see charity i agree
here it is there's a transition i think
that account's made don't insult charity
hey casey i appreciate you making up
that account
it was actually me tweeting under the
desk yeah right but i meant every word
i love laying the bra chicks love you on
there you haven't seen that yeah
he's popular some like the chest hair
some don't well i think it works they're
wrong and i hate them
what do you prefer you like the chest
hair
on
people oh yeah myself
women can take it or leave it yeah i
mean it just depends if there's certain
nationalities where it just comes with
the frame and if the rest is working it
works yeah
you can work it you can work it
it's a confidence thing i've always said
you know nothing like a nice pair of
hairy tits
nice and warm
okay have a long day curlies around the
area oh yeah
let's keep on moving yeah please oh
my goodness
fabulous
just threw his phone across the road
he's like why is he
actually he's probably laughing at that
one
i know i could give him a laugh
that wasn't even dirty come on no
everybody's getting nipples we know that
we all prefer a woman without
yeah
i'm just saying if we took an honest
poll i think everyone would go i like my
breasts hairless yeah
thank you
the ding was
okay yes yes motion
i'm sure there's one guy out there
that's like i totally disagree
i like
i like breasts to look like earmuffs
living in his mother's basement
oh for sure and mother's got hairy
breasts
mother can i feed
so anyway
perhaps the protesters are like
so creepy when somebody calls their mom
mother mother do you hear that in the
stores mommy mother mother may i buy
this and i'm like
you're 35 yeah
yeah because it's never it's weird
take the diaper off
so yeah i always think like since i'm
doing like an old classic car and he's
got a old woman in check because he
spent all his life working on that and
not life yeah like you buy a classic car
once you win
yeah you got a chick that was like into
cars yeah and it's like mother else slow
down
i'm sorry mother
it's his mom's car yeah
yeah that's true she bought it and it's
just been in the garage yeah
pre-inheritance i know you're going to
die soon mother oh my that's the machine
from eight millimeter go to church
mother i want to do bad things
perhaps the protesters are like this
young lady who just enjoys killing
babies y'all these dumbasses were making
a live on tick tock and they were
explaining about how oh pro-life is good
abortions are bad debata all this and
that and i had to pop in and give my two
cents and they were like you know
they're babies it's a human humans have
rights you're gonna kill it that's a
murder and i'm like listen [ __ ] i would
get pregnant just to avoid it you can't
argue with me okay i'm psycho i wouldn't
kill it i would push myself down the
[ __ ] stairs i would jump out of a
plane to kill that baby i do not want to
give birth why wait
[Laughter]
jump on that plane now yes there's
stairs available everywhere terms are
excellent plentiful stairs you're in a
car there's walls
yeah
there are bridges that need to be jumped
off yeah
low ones you know five ten feet
why is it that you would relate it to
being psychotic though if you thought it
was a noble belief yeah yeah isn't that
interesting i'm crazy therefore it's
like subconsciously they know i would
get pregnant just getting abortion well
that's nice i would jump out of a plane
you realize you would kill yourself
right yeah i don't know that you thought
this through no just so you didn't have
to oh psycho though
look at me yeah i'm crazy look at that
i'm wearing a jersey i'll delete myself
i don't even play football
i put my glasses down so the sun hits my
eyes which defeats the purpose of
sunglasses
yeah i look like tlc a little bit
i chase waterfalls i'll also jump down
one if i'm pregnant oh good
the supreme court is scheduled to
release more opinions tomorrow and
thursday yeah you guys excited yeah
so this week we'll see roadway decisions
coming down lane and i were talking
about it with that's going to get crazy
as well we're trying to determine when
they're going to do that probably you
think lane do you think next thursday
probably i would say it would be their
last set of decisions before they
released for the summer recess because i
don't think they want to have to deal
with any of that press or any of the
crap i mean look what's already going on
can you imagine after it's official yeah
they don't want to go to work to work
the next day and face the protests and
everything else this is gonna drop it
day last day all right we're out going
to cancun so we'll see we'll keep you
guys posted we'll we'll be covering it
when it drops they've been doing most of
their drops in the morning around nine
ten o'clock something yeah they're
usually all in by 11 eastern i think and
none of these people are awake at that
time wow do they use the term drop like
it's an album yeah yeah and amy coney
barrett gets down front and gives you
one of these drop it like it's hot
you're in the b-boy stance
i'm amy coney the shackle
oh
no she's not
very bad very boring yeah you don't like
amy coney barrett i like her you like
honey dogs oh she went to youtube
you like coney island she did wait she
was a professor i think at my alma mater
i don't think she went there at notre
dame notre dame our lady where you
played soccer i played american football
oh
well
someone else is from southend indiana
aren't they oh yeah yeah people our man
pete buck
pete buttgig is from south bend indiana
there's big news with butt gig
air travel is starting to get crazy in
the u.s and transport
he's that guy transpo transportation
guys i was laughing i'm sorry yes he's
the uh well emphasis on secretary he's
the transportation secretary butt gig
is warning airlines to step up their
game or
else
of the memorial day meltdown when 2700
flights were canceled nationwide
hopefully people just kind of get there
with like no more complications no more
delays late today transportation
secretary p buddha judge gathered
airline ceos in a virtual meeting asking
for assurances that the rest of the
summer vacation season will go smoothly
i let them know that you know this is a
moment when we're really counting on
them to deliver reliably for the
traveling public look there's a lot of
pent up demand out there among the
biggest choke points florida passenger
traffic has surged more than 100 percent
over pre-pandemic levels at virtually
every airport in the state well it's
almost like people weren't allowed to
travel for a while and now they want to
go to florida strange weird strength
it's very awesome i wonder why i can't i
don't get it
it's also maybe it's cause uh gas is
five uh dollars a gallon
on average perhaps uh airplane fuel has
gone up perhaps perhaps perhaps i have
to pay fourteen hundred dollars for a
ticket to detroit i'm not exaggerating
wow what goodness yeah i'm not kidding
why why would anyone pay 1400 to go
because they're from there otherwise
there's zero reason i'm not [ __ ] i
actually get to sit co-pilot oh
also said his department could take
enforcement actions against airlines
that fall to live fail
gerald just read it they do fall can't
fail to live up to consumer protection
standards and i'm glad you mentioned
this because
this is one of the unintended
consequences segments that we should
probably have at the ready every single
time the government comes in and says
i'm going to force you to do something
in private business they're saying look
if you schedule these flights you have
to have at least this many otherwise we
may find you you know what airlines will
do okay we will schedule fewer flights
and so yeah ticket prices will go up and
there'll be fewer opportunities to
travel because airlines don't have
enough pilots right now his own
department transportation is part of the
problem down in florida that they were
having didn't mention that
and it's pent up demand like you can't
force airlines to do better jobs with
fewer trained pilots yes i want to have
dave after two months of training going
and fly a plane and hopefully not kill
us no i'd rather have a really
well-trained pilot that takes time i'm
pretty good at loop-de-loops now well
there you go on that note though if you
do want to become a pilot now it's
probably the easiest time yeah ever to
do it so you have new dreams dave and
you want to spread your wings i do you
know there's a good shot you can be
flying
yeah
for
school
want to be like john travolta buzz the
tower i'll be like i'll i'll fly the
plane and then i'll put into autopilot
and be like hey
who wants to give me an old hj or this
thing ain't going to land fella probably
pete
this thing won't land itself it's like
yes it could mean itself probably is a
good time though to become a pilot yeah
my friend she flies for american and she
said that they can't get enough
applications in quick enough
no they're just canceling flights all
the time yeah oh i was on one this week
and it was delayed three hours before i
got in and people get furious i'm just
so used to the fact that this is kind of
what it is now yeah i'm just like yeah
whatever i guess i'm just going to read
more go back to the lounge yeah it's not
the end of the world i bet you have a
lounge past year old i do yeah i do too
but i don't go in there
i do i think it's uppity i don't care
what do they have in the lounge it's
just like free food and a place to sit
it's it's really not
it's only because i have like so many
miles on delta but it's like ooh
croissants
yeah it's worth it yeah yay
extra how much day old bread 400 400
yeah but you get like bonus miles like
it works out if you travel if you're
doing a lot yeah i have a credit card
for it so that's the only reason okay
gerald we get it geez no i'm saying no
me too i get it i roll it out you get it
that you're bragging mine makes sense
i'm not bragging at all
san francisco airport three and a half
hours early one time by accident
i guess you want to get there early i'm
just gonna go into the airport lounge
i'll pay the 50 day fee and they're like
you know for 200 bucks you could
probably have a pass for the year and
i'm like what yeah you walk into the
airport lounge in san francisco it's
just a bathroom with holes in the stall
exactly so on the people taking dumps
everywhere like huh want to make you
feel like san francisco don't use the
best great
well on the same day that butt ga uh gig
but gage yeah on booty booty gage large
gauge
butt butter buns uh his own flight from
washington to new york was cancelled
forcing him to use a very special rental
car service
because i had a lot of dogs when i was
it's going to take extra time
but who can blame them you know they do
have a pretty awesome marketing campaign
mac why don't you go ahead and operate
the bike
yeah
sure
problem just just like any other workout
bike well
it pedals
oh
there you go it's outrageous yeah there
it is i mean it's just the craziest okay
all right all right all right okay
i know what you're thinking okay but it
is not what it looks like
classic
i wonder if this bike does that also be
sure to share the show right now if you
can yeah enjoying it i'm enjoying it
hope you're enjoying it and also again
don't forget to comment see how much you
love stuff or how much uh you don't i
don't really i don't care yeah
let us know i do care massively insecure
hate comments or comments you know they
come true or comments that's
interactions thanks for watching but
honestly yeah let also let us know what
uh
again what's the worst father's day gift
you've ever given or received comment
he did he left you on that branch
and it cracked that hurt comment
i can't do it again watch this
rumble rumble
can you do it again
rubble
[Laughter]
go to rumble
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh man
all right guys this is pretty important
okay yeah serious face let's get some
serious faces on here fellas big boy
pants big deal here
on sunday june 19th
congressman adam kinzinger
of the january 6th committee
heads to say about future violence
there are people that
there is violence in the future i'm
going to tell you and until we get a
grip on something people the truth we
can't expect any differently
hmm he had no idea how right he would be
and here's footage from juneteenth
mochella celebration in washington d.c
no that is straight up gunshots
mostly peaceful celebration
yes
is that sophia vargara narrating the
video oh yes it is
it's a lot of shows look at it yeah
it go pop up
are you telling me that's washington dc
yes the gun safe
what yeah it's so gun free ridiculous
yeah i mean it's mostly gun free mostly
like that was like majority no are we
sure that wasn't cheyenne wyoming it
could have been i think it might have it
could have been
but according to the chief of police the
event was promoted on social media but
was not authorized
this
evening
around the six o'clock hour there was an
unpermitted event
that took place in the 1400 block of u
street and while this event was going on
apparently this started on social media
several hundred people began to gather
in the area of the 1400 block of u
street
most of the group was contained
initially to the sidewalk
mpd members responded to the area
to assist
in fairness they did go to get a
juneteenth permit and they were like oh
what
everyone's like huh for that it's
juneteenth like what is like we've
looked through everything i got nothing
the 16th we didn't make the 18. what's
the etymology behind that like what is
teen like uh june 19th june 18th yeah
it's like an ebonics thing it's science
it's like the 18th and 17th there's
tenths in all of these so i just there
are yes i'm just confused yeah forgive
the ignorance no no i it's a good point
i i i remember a crack addict tried to
sell me a little girl's bicycle for 11
cents that happened once it's a good
deal you know like i guess so and you
bought it does it hi
did it have the bell it did not that was
what was upsetting yeah
i was like what am i going to do if
biden falls because he needs the bell to
give me something
sound in the darkness can i have a bell
just in case uh i need help i i was
going to look up what uh like where
juneteenth comes from and do you want to
see what happens if you google
juneteenth oh i hate oh yes i do oh no
do you know why i hate this it's not
because
of june
is that the palestine flag i don't know
what it is i think it's jamaica isn't it
i don't know what it is jamaican flank
it's one they just you're making me
crazy yeah no kidding the reason i hate
this is because when you do this is when
you play the applause
thank you guys come on yeah i was trying
to call back to them nope
these guys you can't force the applause
no i think that was the time to do it i
miss you gary i'll miss you too
look at me that's not offense to anybody
else no no don't get all worked up just
have a special connection we're just
friends two of us right over here just
mean you i mean everybody else lovers
right gerald no
full time
okay overtime
overtime lover
overtime lovers
and night shift too
anyway let's well let's be more serious
about this though what we do know
honestly about the shooting is uh one
fifteen-year-old was shot dead oh three
others wounded including one officer
there was an earlier violent altercation
which people also
fled on foot
[Applause]
it's a celebration yes it's the running
of the [ __ ]
[Applause]
the police did not close the event
though that's insane how many times can
you have people running from an event
where they're like i think it's safe to
go back
yeah cc yeah this is like every day i
don't understand yeah well
everyone thinks that a celebration
marking the end of the worst institution
of american history is a great idea yes
i have no problem like for example uh
today
the stock market is shut down is it
which i think is exciting that after 156
years they decided to finally do that
[Music]
good job guys you can tell that it's
sincere when uh over a century and a
half later they're like oh let's
acknowledge this yeah the abolishment of
slavery
and this this is it's very interesting
to me because they're not like we the
emancipation proclamation was almost two
years prior to this that should be in my
opinion the date but i understand why
having yeah because this is like the
final but sort of official sort of
because it's when union soldiers showed
up in galveston bay
and free and let them know like read
this proclamation to them letting them
know that they were free they had to
show up in force to make sure that they
could enforce this in former confederate
states but i don't think that was the
last group to find out right that's when
they finally showed up in texas there
were probably groups after that as well
so it's almost arbitrary that they're
picking that day
to celebrate i'm like can we just put it
on the emancipation proclamation day
because that's when
a white guy and a bunch of white
soldiers and black soldiers died to free
slaves and we should be celebrating that
all together did you have to open with
white guy well i did because it's like
you said exist
that's true that's the problem
i don't have a well june teen started in
texas right wasn't that the whole
galveston yeah
that's it's interesting that we have to
have two different holidays because
information traveled so slowly yeah well
and confederate people were just saying
no we're not going to do it so of course
that you mean you should be like all
right idiots like the emancipation
proclamation was signed but correct me
do it if i'm wrong this is something i
should definitely have a better grip on
there's never been a federal holiday
surrounding the emancipation
proclamation no correct so
i think it should be yeah absolutely
i'll take both houses that's why it just
seems like the messaging here is not
really about framing the slaves at all
it doesn't seem it just seems like some
sort of strange cultural yeah
yeah it's not really about the event
itself it's about the
outward appearance of going look how
virtuous we are celebrating this right
now like google when you type in
on google juneteenth you get this thing
so then go look at us we're doing the
song and dance like we got your thing
right it's nice oh you got a black
friend that's what google is doing
because i think we all we all know if we
remember history that when slavery ended
there was confetti
not to overshadow father's day at all
no it's not meant for that whatsoever
well that's what sucks is it really is
about separating races again and just
making something up to be divisive
that's all that it really comes down to
i'm not saying making it up in the fact
that it didn't happen it did and it
should be celebrated but then throwing
in the holiday out of nowhere and
pandering
156 years later or really 158 years
later like you've said yeah is pointless
and obvious right which is why i pointed
out that abraham lincoln was white and
that white people died
no no but not to say it was just to say
that that should bring us together right
we were all on the same page the reason
you know it's not supposed to bring us
together is how many american flags are
being flown to celebrate exactly zero
yeah go ahead please i'm just gonna say
that we have this flag that unites us
together already
so if we want to be united we would use
this flag as that symbol but no one does
that because that's not the goal of this
no it's to separate conquer and divide
just like everything in the last 10
years yeah the ones that i do look like
to see are the ones that have american
flags because it's it's finally showing
hey you are american you are now free
that's such an american story
that that should be the focal point is
that we're all together we're all
together in this but it's not it's like
you just said just separating everybody
again
showing different colors different flags
it's it should be about america finally
like rising up and going no this is a
bad thing we should undo this
it's uh yeah it's
well it's about people in power that
will get more power by by dividing it
yeah and then you also have corporations
that are out there that'll make more
money off of you know the attempted
juneteenth ice cream like walmart did
which i think
they accidentally made it a gay thing or
something because it was june and they
were like we didn't know oops like we
have no idea
what's going on the original juneteenth
flag looked like this
and now it has changed into this
they call it a pan-african flag ah
pan-african
tell someone in africa that they're
pan-african and see how well that goes
you know what yeah no kid you know what
the youtube troops showed up they said
hey by the way you guys are free here's
the flag and they were like yes thank
god we're free they weren't like hey we
got to make something else now so that
that signifies that this country
bled and died for us i think we'll all
jump behind the stars and stripes right
well and what happened to the original
fly that you just showed that was uh
drawn by a kid
ms paint yeah
is it really what what when was that
first juneteenth flag made
uh
i gotta look into it it was like it was
1997 oh yeah
way back in the day yeah
140 years yeah
yeah ot flag back in 97. back when
jordan was still a bull dude right
[Laughter]
we really are just going to keep being
divided and divided if we don't and
there's look it's totally fine if this
is something that you want to celebrate
you should you should be happy that
you're free that it's a free country you
shouldn't do that by dividing everybody
exactly doing it by unifying everybody
and you shouldn't overlap other holidays
with it which they're deliberately doing
you're being insulting to people by
doing it you're being insulting to black
fathers by doing it yeah i mean that's
just my i honestly it's it it enforces
it reinforces
stereotypes it it hurts families it's
like it's just
you can be happy that we're a free
country
enjoy father's day as well you don't
have to do this observe [ __ ] you don't
have to pardon my language but it's no
it's just all such pandering yeah it's
the same as a month of gay pride parades
and everything why
so you can sell doritos and at the end
you're like oh yeah rainbow
by the way
we're selling a product to you
well that's the problem is if if
anything right now was anti if the
popular thing of the day was to be
anti-gay
every single corporation would be
hopping on that there's no authenticity
to any of this
no i think disney's authentic too to
their gay agenda but other than that
i think that once it starts if
everything keeps tanking at the box
office oh then watch it change yeah well
they fired the the head of tv
did they just recently development yeah
he just like unceremoniously just fired
him
what did they give him his severance two
kids
here you go yeah
two little transgender kids here's your
basket of molesties
have fun
but i think you're right like once once
money doesn't come in anymore they're
gonna drop this stuff yeah but it it
takes the audience a long time for them
to come around and go wait wait this
this crap sucks why are we paying for
this i'm just gonna stay home and wait
maverick i'll go watch maverick yeah it
just looks like jets
cool who like i don't know any gay
people that were like i can't i can't
watch tim ellen do a voice yeah this is
horrible i can't believe him this is
terrible it's like a handful of people
on twitter and they're probably bots
more than likely
yeah well a lot of them are yeah
have you ever tested that theory where
you just put out a certain thing and
then you see how many people come at you
and you realize it's bots saying the
exact same thing for an agenda it's very
scary yeah
anyway twitter is so fake
it's the worst it's like you find a real
person yeah
but usually they're awful as well but
yeah
there's some decent people yeah i i was
talking about uh ezra miller and his
crimes
i did a video about it and the first
thing that i got was flash yeah the
flash yeah the hero superhero flash
which is a bunch of grooming interesting
uh interestingly and uh the the comment
was uh
can you not
mispronoun him okay you're misgendering
him
like there's no need to misgender him
uh he's just a bad person okay i'm like
why do we give him respect
you're missing you're missing the point
nothing just because he's grooming
children
doesn't mean you have to misgender him
look people are gonna really get hurt
here
i want to hear more about that behind
the pay wall have you not heard about
the flash something that we oh man talk
about it yeah he plays the flash yeah
kidnap someone yeah
and just snatching kids
but fortunately he doesn't misgender
people but he knows exactly
who he's kidnapping
so
well dave you have a date coming up too
right july 15 16 columbus ohio big date
back in ohio i'm kidding uh yes actually
we uh in columbus ohio july 15 and 16.
and again uh don't forget to check us
out me and steven we are touring around
the country
with uh our uh
devils without a cause rebels we're
going platinum a cause
and then uh of course you can catch me
in michigan on july 9th but until then
we got some stuff behind the paywall
we're going to be talking about how
fina bans trans swimmers i don't know if
you hear about that yeah i saw that ooh
saucy yeah
we're gonna talk about the flash a
little bit too oh wow we got our comic
book friend on here i'd like to thank uh
qb lane both you for joining us today
thank you sir and piss off youtube